hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to homecoming starring
markiplier now this is made by the same
person that made a new home starring
markiplier and then homesick starring
mark blyer which are both markiplier fan
games and I've said my name way too many
times now but it's getting a little
awkward but their fan games and I spent
a long time since I played one of these
and I wanted to play this one for a
while now a but I wanted to get the
other RPG horror game that I was playing
out of the way and now that I have I
finally have time to play these cool
games that people have made for me and
I'm very eager to see what they have in
store hi
what is this stuff No the recipe was
called sunrise sandwich it's good right
well yeah well it's the green stuff oh
that's called whack-a-mole eh yeah but
what is it though
it's mushed up caterpillars yeah I don't
eat that
I was just teasing a bluebird it's made
from a fruit called an avocado some
people call them alligator pears ha ha
ha door that's right they're very good
for you you sure it's not made of bugs
about the avocados myself so go eat up
we're all to grow up healthy so you can
make a difference like your old man huh
huh okay and speaking of that it's about
that time now off to work Jenna should
be here any minute I made her a sandwich
to make sure she sees it okay I love you
love you too Bluebird Hey
right now our time is done hey but I
will be the Sun okay then all right a
little odd oh good now down to the crawl
space Tony bug zoom oh I can't keep
hiding in here the thing came back from
that trip isn't my mark it's a monster
but I can't hide this time I have to be
brave the first thing I need to do is
call the real mark I'll have to find a
place where I get a good psychic signal
because apparently that's outside the
box Tim communicates with me oh man I'm
not gonna do that voice through the
whole thing because number will always
got little walking animation oh I don't
want to go out there the monster might
find me
oh no he's so cute oh he's so adorable
oh my god that is the cutest thing okay
I can run which probably to help me
because I'm probably gonna need to run
away from monster that seems like a loop
that is specifically designed to do that
ah
this seems like a good place contact
mark now I'm gonna explore more because
apparently there's an option to explore
more and that usually means that there's
something else here someone filled with
squishy stuff wouldn't survive a fall
down this hole I would though but then
I'd be stuck well I better make another
psychic signal then at least I know
where to run away great calling mark I
just have to focus and our love will
link us together no matter what
Oh
it's probably not true but oh that's
adorable
anybody know Tim is that you it's me yes
where are you Marc I'm at the hospital
what are you hurt no no I'm fine someone
here was trying to reach me that's all
listen you have to hide okay this is a
crazy monster headed to the house he's
already here he looks just like you but
he's really stinky
well I'm a pretty stinky man as it is so
I don't know if that's a big
differentiation and I don't want to hide
this time I'm gonna help you out just
tell me what I should do mmm I suppose I
would like to know what that thing's up
to thinking and sneak around a bit for
me sounds really scary but I'll do it
for you great just be careful he knows a
lot about me so it probably knows you
too there's no telling what he'll do if
he catches you hopefully I won't be here
too long
ah Hilary here I'll hurry home soon okay
oh that sounds bad gotta go I'll talk to
you soon better make sure he doesn't see
me hello okay was a bit of a stir ttle
okay so apparently there's I gotta get a
round of his I know I know that's the
thing okay yep okay got it got it got it
got it got it got it got it got it got
it oh yeah I got it
that was too close and how do I get
around the stinky thing to leave this
place you might not be that stinky no no
okay so I got to get his attention over
here I'm assuming can I swim oh great
right so we've gotta get his attention
here hey stinky face Oh No well that
didn't work out
no no why it didn't work out but it
didn't work out okay let's try that
again damn it aw [ __ ] all right whatever
[ __ ] buckets all right I'm gonna get
around you and you're gonna suck it
showed once I'm done with you go eat a
bag of dicks fake me okay so now that
I'm over here there's like III think I
had the right attitude about it oh god
damn it he did the thing again how's
that
I know
oh god damn it what a bag of dicks this
guy is what a second [ __ ] oh what a load
of ghoul ass and I'm just gonna load up
not pro enough I'm pro enough I'm about
the most Pro than ever proud you don't
know how much Pro I Pro alright I'm
gonna get through this huh hey there
would you be willing to take one for the
team for Team Tim in a silly accent why
of course I would friend you're too kind
oh no you look fine really I can art ah
so this is smarter come tomorrow I want
to play better go I'm having trouble
trying to remember exactly what happened
in the last it's been so long I should
have rewatched it like I have a vague
idea I'm not completely lost I've
actually been here before and this is
actually pretty much pretty familiar I'd
help you out but I don't have thumbs
cheerleaders need oh that's adorable
oh everything he thinks about the world
is adorable no if there's a valise it's
always been advised it will always be a
Vaz it is timeless
okay oh so cute so cute the studio I
remember I remember now Oh looks like he
emailed someone about some medical
supplies maybe he's trying to make sure
his fake body stays healthy and the
order some bread - bread is good for
people right as far as I remember now
let's see if he's tried to make any
video posting as Mark yes let's take a
look huh
okay all right I can't let this be
posted this is the worst markiplier
video ever you mean all of my videos his
voice is so monotone this game he picked
is super boring he's saying stuff mark
wouldn't say and he's just terrible at
the game - well that third thing I would
invent that might be me
and pretty much that second thing and
also the first thing and all of the
things at least he got one thing right
oh you okay I'm gonna leave these videos
before he gets a chance to post any of
them
that'll stall him for a while there we
go all done
wait hoops I didn't mean to delete that
video that was mark's video where he
completed vanish i'm beat it what does
everyone think that i didn't beat vanish
i beat it just because I beat the
updated version doesn't mean that I
didn't beat it I beat it
whatever I'll continue my investigation
now yeah sure whatever
alright sure oh it's not that powerful I
need a new computer I'm still using the
computer that I made when I first got
here to LA medical companies he using
marks money I have no idea but I better
save just in case something horrible
happens okay goodbye come out in a potty
you don't have to hide from me
Oh better be careful oh [ __ ] oh I can't
go this way okay I see how this is I'm
gonna get this all right hello ah a nice
glowing thing I don't think the monster
would have done very much in here I
doubt I'll find anything important well
what about this glowing thing hey you
wrote this looks like I wrote it but I
didn't I'm tiny box Tim and I love
unicorn hole I think I have an idea what
unicorn hole means and I think that has
anything to do with anything
all righty then wonder how many of these
have actually read well I don't have a
library so not very many Spirit is
damned to wander the realm on top of
ours if it lingers for too long by
finding true peace however some may
finally pass on okay
don't let your dreams be dreams just do
it okay are you sure maybe I don't know
memories of the past will grant ingress
but do the ends truly justify the means
probably not I have no idea what you're
talking about but I'm pretty sure I got
what I needed to get okay where you
going little buddy somebody's shooting
whoa that's too close too close to
colostomy okay goodbye all right so what
do we got in here nothing looks out of
place okay okay the bodies in the fridge
nothing weird in the freezer a microwave
yummy stuff doesn't eat hmm
lots of bread go Oh No maybe you
probably shouldn't I don't know if tiny
box stem would be able to fight like
this Wow
oh I know you're here Timothy I felt
that energy spike earlier it's just a
matter of dragging you down no I must
have alerted this weirdo when I
contacted mark earlier got a feeling I
know just where you are - I can't move
oh I wanna do this but I'm gonna have to
oh been fun playing hide-and-seek with
you little party but it's game over for
you
haha well [ __ ] I could have sworn
where are you worm he's a box not a worm
ah good move Tim good move really stuck
it to him slave cuz that was such a good
move right move there little buddy
Oh [ __ ] I was gonna call on the
phone but I got a little sidetracked he
no time Louis time you could have done
it okay here we go don't know where
we're going now but we're probably
supposed to go in here oh the butt
stabber was in this area of course you
don't have any hands you have hands like
mitten hands or the most feared
paranormal creatures a spooky skeleton I
don't know I can't do it you can't do it
why can't you do it I can't leave
without checking the shower I have to be
brave there could be something there
that Marc needs to know about I just
have to be babe I don't know about that
okay I can do this anybody there I've
never been happier to see nothing well
good job Tim Tim is just so adorable
they did a great job of a contempt
seemed absolutely adorable a decorative
glass container which holds a seed
bearing attractive part of a certain
species of plants the pedals are
brightly covered if you were B you would
likely be attracted to this like a
lumberjack lumberjack is it - beef jerky
I don't know about that analogy I've
never been a lumberjack before this is a
cute little mustachio bear someone need
for more
not familiar medical supplies this is
Mark's and rods I wasn't prepared when I
made my first attempt I was rash I
underestimated my target I never would
have guessed he'd learned as much as he
did so fast with no help of prior
knowledge it seems mr. Fishbach has a
knack for the supernatural perhaps due
to his constant ventures in the
paranormal situations and maybe from
some other event in his life
whatever the case are afford to back
down after spending some time studying
him for my second attempt I found that
he was now immune to my efforts but I
couldn't give up my perfect target my
persistence led to an opportunity to
snatch a body that was close enough a
lowly skinwalker I finally assembled all
the necessary supplies but I'm now faced
with one finally this rancid body may be
too twitchy for me to operate I'm going
to have to it just stops must be where
he realized I was contacting mark what's
this guy can operate on himself has he
become bigger scarier monster I need to
call mark again but I can't do it from
here uh-uh I want to leave the house not
safe for me outside I'll have to think
of a place where a monster won't follow
just leave a little nothing ah good move
DBT was here you stink loser okay whoa
months of doing experiments not even
tried to get in the chest love - got a
lot better down - stay focused mirror
mirror on the wall who's the cutest
biscuit of them all okay okay
nothing there chime hi holy [ __ ] Wow
okay hey there little buddy why don't we
play together
oh well I'm boned oh don't be that way
Oh
move move buddy I got a run for don't I
you can run but you can't hide not
anymore
okay run
oh wow they connected at all they
connected it all holy [ __ ] I did it I
made it
couple Oh fee Oh ouchies come on stinky
pretend mark jump down I dare ya
yeah go ahead and call them all you want
you can't do much to stand in my way
from down there now can you all I need
to do is tell mark what I've learned and
he'll take care of you and then get me
out of here I just focus our love will
link us once more oh the power of love
triumphs all Tim mark hey is everything
okay yeah I'm fine I had a run-in with
the monster but I was too fast for him
good if anything happened to my little
biscuit I'd go crazy don't worry about
me hey so I read them what the monster
wrote in your diary he said all he has
tools need to finish his plan but the
body he's using might not work huh of
course you can't having laid all this he
should have known so what's the plan
anyway he didn't really write it so I'm
not sure but he didn't mention operating
I think he's gonna turn himself into
even more of a monster
he didn't order a bunch of medical
supplies well and he had my body but I
thought that and the bread was just to
piss me off by reminding me a surgeon
simulator and I am bread I guess there's
more to it than that
do you think he's gonna turn himself
into a bread monster oh god I hope not
if he does he's toast let me go meet
this lady who needed me when I'm done
I'll head home and deal with them okay
okay
oh hello come on in mr. Fishbach thank
you disconcerting nurse hi hello I'm
nurse Hale thank you so much for coming
to meet me it's urgent
I was thinking that might be the case
how'd you know the 14 missed calls were
a bit of a hint huh I hope I can help
this is Sophie she's been a coma she's
been for about seven years now
yes I don't exactly know her but I've
known her a long time you know anyway
she's been stable since he arrived here
she has some other health problems that
would have killed her by now but it
seems her coma is halted their
progression the medical community is
closed to occur a cure for other issues
so in a weird way the coma is a good
thing keeps her alive until we find the
cure we just need her to stay healthy a
bit longer
then when she wakes up she can get back
on track to live a normal life I know we
can save this girl she's a fighter
she has been for as long as I've known
her it may sound silly to you but I know
she'll come out of it soon well
in the past weeks she started to
deteriorate came out of nowhere and we
can't figure out why she's getting worse
by the day try just about everything but
I have one more idea one that I can't
share with my colleagues an idea that I
need your help with hmm how can I help I
need you to keep this between us I could
get in trouble for getting you involved
or even telling you what I have told you
thus far of course I don't know why you
call me medicine is physical all these
machines monitor your body and we use
tools and drugs to keep her healthy but
we both know there's more you've
experienced the next realm I chose you
because you've been outside of your body
not by choice but you've done it how do
you know this how do you know this about
me and beyond that you learned how to
create manifestations of creatures and
one your body back all on your own it's
unbelievable
thank you I know I've studied these
things for years and haven't been able
to do what you did so I need you to use
your natural skills with via
supernatural I need you to exit your
body once more I believe you're gonna
reach Sophia this way I would love to
help but I don't know how to do that
that's the honest truth
I don't have a [ __ ] clue oh don't
worry
the rules and techniques memorized I
just need you to apply them great cool
I'll give it a shot what should I say
though what did I tell her well I think
I know why she's fading I believe she's
taught herself how to do what I'm asking
you to do now if you probably know a
spirit can only remain outside his
bodies for seven days before the bond
breaks then the spirit will remain as
such forever I think she's coming
dangerously close to the seven day mark
so I just tell her to wait it out in her
body right and that you should be able
to wake her up soon yes that's perfect
oh say how long were you outside of your
body honestly it was on the seventh day
that I got my body back but I think I
have enough time left to do this at
least want to try oh so it's like a
continual thing if I spend like one more
hour outside my body I'll be all borked
that's very kind of you it's the other
reason I asked you I was certain you'd
say yes believe it or not I have
something equally as pressing going on
elsewhere if you don't mind I'd like to
jump right into this madness
of course I'll explain everything you
need to know on our way down down which
is right here I can't very well have
your lifeless body lying around now can
i there are other nurses on duty we're
headed to the basement oh yeah this
seems safe and a lot of non murdery I'm
sure I'm gonna walk out of this just
fine when I go into the spirit realm oh
no it was the seventh day OOP
so he's dead before we go can I just
this is I have to do okay wait why
nothing is it's a habit let's come don't
mind me sooner tailed explained all the
important detail two marks you left him
in the bed meant to attempt the feed
then after a great deal did come to
retire
I did it oh hi oh jeez
is that me Wow I don't look so good
okey-dokey then
I guess oh well it's gotta go I'm moving
okay never mind then some piece of
medical equipment I gasps looks like a
broken-down vending machine I'm so
hungry you're a spirit don't worry about
it you're fine
electrical bill lots of clever things to
look at man I gotta remember that I look
at just about everything on here I gotta
move on yeah things to do nothing I need
I'm sure but I am curious I sure AM are
nice so I got to move up okay nurse al
said the hospital would different when
we came down she said the spirits here
will affect what I see I can handle this
I still don't know why I'm a part of it
oh hey how's it going that's a bit of a
problem since I have to keep an eye out
from the leveling spirits she said they
tend to have red eyes when angered she
said that good also damaged my soul and
I'm assuming she means even more than
the Lion King did what is that supposed
to mean okay okay okay COO hello I've
gone running every day since I was 14 I
don't drink or smoke so I'm healthy it
only makes sense or gay thanks buddy why
did I tell oh I thought the music
dropped out for a second there there
usually signifies you something horrible
about to happen all right everything's
fine not possible to open the lockers
from the spirit realm
I should stop actually trying to open
all the things and look at all the
things because I know they're probably
not gonna be open okay hello I don't
recognize you no point in getting
acquainted really I'll be out on my way
out in a few so these are lost souls
just stuck here in this plane of
existence tied to the hospital okay
hello oh oh hey your markiplier right
this is quite absurd dream Oh No all
right all my way things are looking like
they're getting a bit more dense
hey who's back here I don't know what's
taking them so long to get back I hope
they're okay they're they're coming back
I don't know don't be negative this is
but come back I know it just have to
wait a bit longer okay
save it just in case because I have a
funny feeling there's about to be a
demon ghost with red eyes and a lot of
anger looking me down hey there sweetie
whoa jeez man your face holy [ __ ] Wow
okay
hi I'm just here to pick someone up now
where could she be
I don't know whew okay
wait was there something probably in
there oh I can't go back down okay I'll
say I got it saved there I got here
first get lost where did you claim the
bathroom screw you could take you oh you
ain't so tough
alright well we got here there's no way
in
what do you want me to do about it I'm
not your mother
well I didn't want to shove this thing
out the way but it won't budge from this
angle well why don't well I don't know
what you want from me then oh he moved
oh we moved are you upset about it you
gonna do something
no hmm okay anything in the toilets no
absolutely not okay
hello everyone knows what's good for me
what I should do everyone knows better
than me eat this don't say that I'm sick
of it
okay good for you how many monitors do
they need I don't know a lot probably
okay weird I don't know I I know how to
take bodies from people you don't look
familiar you didn't leave a body lying
around did you better hope I don't find
it well that's a little malicious thank
you very much for that reassuring word
you shouldn't be here it isn't safe
thank you I know well well what good
with that what good did oh I need to
push it from the other side okay I got
it you're not listening to me I told you
it's dangerous here I'm gonna show you
oh good
then
you can't get me I'm the gingerbread man
boy that oh how was I supposed to give
away how am I supposed to be able to do
this you're gonna show me yeah whatever
Wow
what the hell lady I didn't know that
you were also part of this adventure
yeah okay got it got it got it got it
okay well a little bit stressful but I
did it nonetheless because I'm great
save the game already the game I already
know how to save the game I got this on
lock don't worry about me I got it now
let's see if I can resolve at least a
little bit of something bata made
breakfast like I said I would then we
wouldn't have left so early and then we
wouldn't have even been here all that
sad that's a terrible way to think about
things can't change what's happened baby
show all kinds of complex charts and
readings textbooks cost a fortune
hello lady are you gonna try to kill me
it was his fault he wasn't paying enough
attention he could have avoided this I
don't know what you're talking about
couldn't open this thing if I want to do
which I kind of do you got that right
food has grown moldy for kids in the
waiting room to play with deep I don't
think I have a stomach I love to eat but
I don't think I have a stomach okay I
gotta be getting close now why is this
bed is all rumpled oh hello
hey is that you do you think they'd have
done more if I had more money maybe they
didn't think I could afford the best
treatment well who's getting sad about
the hospital on all its inhabitants just
one more year just one more year what's
that mean one more year until what why
did I go on with such bad habits how is
I so stupid I wish I could go back and
beat my own ass oh man self-aware
sadness control the flow of whatever's
in these pipes okay weird hello there
has to be something worthy of trade
around here I'll let you pass if you
bring me five things of value if I get a
hold of the right things and maybe I can
make some sort of deal I'd give anything
just got to have the right thing to give
right okay sure is this valuable
this is pipe valuable ok so there's got
to be like five things that are valuable
right about okay gob microscope blue
lenses
huh found something a gameboy oh okay
let's value anyway anything in here nup
nothing okay foods going moldy no value
there anything in the trash can
I'm scrubs
okay new scrubs that should be for
things ah textbooks they must be worth a
fortune okay so that's probably enough
things that I need what this is double
check okay so I think I got everything
that I need I should be able to go down
to the exit now hello let's see what you
got for me a whole bunch of stuff I
don't think there's enough you don't
think this is enough I don't know if
anything is enough surely it's got to be
something out there I can trade to get
back what can I do I have to get it back
well you aren't gonna be able to help me
go ahead and go oh really okay well that
was sad and depressing what was that all
about
oh boy there's got the dark one oh no no
no hello I don't need to go back to my
room it's easier to stay here okay
I don't think the spirits do that I
don't think the spirits put blood on the
ground either all right anyway I'm
actually all out of time for this
episode but this is gonna be really cool
I love playing these games that people
make for me I'm honored that anyone
would take the time to make them in the
first place and it's always fun because
it's a trip down memory lane and
recapping some of the favorite moments
in people's minds in you guys's minds so
I'm hoping you're enjoying it too and I
can't wait to get to the end of this
this has been a great series if you want
to check out the other videos in this
series you can check it out in the
description below
I'll put him in the annotation thank you
everybody so much for watching this
really let it sink in how awkward
meeting